merci lancer dans cet agrès
alors première question c'est quand la
dernière fois que vous avez plus de
temps
personnes de l'âge ils branchent pas de
ne prendre le temps c'est pas a
effectivement vraiment content ou le
classique je suis désolé gerra chambre
par de vraies discussions sur des sujets
philosophiques sur le débat à malte dont
le pen sur le féminisme tout même
l'histoire du roi de france vraiment
déçu tout à fait banal comme
ça avait déjà parrainé à 6,6
en fait je vous comprends pas ce que
l'on peut dire au premier abord qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire en discutant
emploi je les ai 17 personnes à sortir
de la rue moi je lui lis des têtes à
tout pour un hébergement
comment est ce que je pourrais l'énergie
dans un tract a eu aucune idée en plus
en avant son rôle de l'état de son genou
et on
apprécie ce qu'on peut dire c'est
comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
malgré ça pour créer du lien social est
que ces personnes
et moi je pense que j'ai la solution je
pense que j'ai la solution en fait créé
du lien social d'abord vous posez la
question c'est pourquoi de bien social
c'est assez simple définition ses
connexions avec une autre personne en
fait le lien social
si la forge qui nous lie tous ensemble
c'est la force qui vous lie au manteau
rouge ali c'est la force qui vous dit à
vos camarades à décoller c'est la force
qui ont mis tous ensemble en tant que
français par exemple parce que le bât
blesse car but en finale le lien social
c'est quelque chose
le sang et qu'est-ce que ça devant le
lien social s'allume en avons tout autre
chose du temps le lien social de monde
du temps selon le ssi de l'empathie pour
se mettre à la place de quelqu'un te
demande aussi de sentir que la relation
vous apporte quelque chose au premier
abord le lien se fait à la demande du
temps
du coup la dream team de trop qui nous
reste j'essaie de vous présenter à quel
point c'est important
que vous preniez le temps de discuter
avec des personnes en situation de
grande difficulté
je vais vous montrer à quel point c'est
la meilleure chose à la fois pour deux
mais aussi pour vous
alors par où commencer ou excuse moi
j'ai commencé je vous dirais que lui par
le hasard des rencontres
en fait c'est comme ça qu'on vante la
destinée des souverains et moi la honte
qui m'a le plus marqué cette année c'est
celle avec merville il ya trois ans sam
j'ai rencontré scarano de la rue est en
fait dans une disposition qui va dire
pour être dans la rencontre puisque
j'étais en stage chaque du temps
disponible et surtout jarente recréer un
projet pour aider des personnes de la
rue on dirait que c'est plus facile au
crédit n'y avait personne dans la rue
dans ce cas là en fait ce qui a été
déterminant qui a vu que j'ai créé ce
lien
physiquement c'est que lui et une
finesse d'esprit de m'aborder en
demandant aux poulets rôtis et ça sera
inférieure soutenir un truc spécial
entre personnes et une connexion qui
s'écriaient instantanément et du coup je
vais lui acheter un objet on a commencé
à parler discuter en échange et on s'est
revus quelques jours après elle que
quelques semaines qui viennent on pense
à ces trois ans pour ce que toi tu fais
tout ce que je peux vous dire que cette
relation depuis trois ans elle lausanne
énormément apporté 8 cheveux
dans un premier temps est rapporté avoir
alors d'un nid de comprendre ce que
c'est et que l' écoute des besoins
d'autrui notamment des personnes en
situation de précarité ce que la
première chose que j'ai fait est légal
quand je lui ai acheté la loose et je
voulais acheter du riz je ne dois pas
posé la question de court il fallait
faire pour cuisiner du riz en notant un
juge
ce que j'aurais dû faire en plus d'avoir
un peu de bon sens et non bâti c'est
tout simplement que les clés aimablement
d'un poulet rôti sur l'adultère poulets
rôtis
cette relation elle aussi énormément
apporté à merville en fait j'étais eu le
soutien dont ils avaient besoin pour
l'accompagner dans ses démarches afin de
sortir de la rue il a commencé en le
faisant c'est un pied il a ensuite
continué en se mobilisant pour trouver
un travail et dans une fille entre dans
l'appartement
ce qui s'est passé dans les ruines texas
des années qu'il avait perdu le froid en
les institutions en les associations et
qu' il attendait que 5,9 et encore
aujourd'hui l'achèvement de vol il me
dit à quel point cette relation elle
haïti
extrêmement importante et l'usagé de la
force
mais voilà nous coûter j'allais pas du
tout cette impression j'ai juste
l'impression de l'est du temps aussi
simple que ça
cette province orientale et des
personnes de la roue allait permis
notamment ça m'a permis de rencontrer
environ une cinquantaine de ces familles
de six de ses camarades et en
rencontrant ces personnes me suis rendu
compte de la réalité leur quotidien et
c'est ça qui m'a permis de creech valeur
le talent aujourd'hui j'en suis très
reconnaissant envers berwyn
est en fait qu'à l'ordinaire s'était
créé pour lutter contre la précarité et
est ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on se greffant
comme on peut le faire pour lutter
efficacement entre un car et et on est
identifié une poche de précarité qui est
le sujet des jeunes en situation de
rupture communales ou des jeunes majeurs
qui ont entre 18 et 25 ans qui n'ont
plus le soutien leurs parents en ce
moment les banques beaucoup d'entre eux
n'étaient pas éligibles aux aides de
l'état rsa bourse garantie jeune parent
porte et du cous est dans une situation
où vous n'avez aucune environnement
familial plus d'être financière comment
est ce que vous pouvez faire vous en
servir jeu qu'on a mis en place il
différent avec celle ordinaire c'est un
premier dispositif de soutien financier
d'un conventionnel pour financer ces
jeunes pourquoi je vous parle de ça pour
vous montrer que le lien social bien
qu'il soit extrêmement important mais
pas suffisant les il est nécessaire il
n'est pas suffisant en fait il est
tellement nécessaire qu'au bout de
quelques mois d'activité le genoa d1 on
a créé un second problème et vous
l'aurez deviné c'est un poulain basé sur
du lien social
pour moi c'est pertinent de créer du
lien social pour des jeunes majeurs en
rupture familiale
en fait si on reprend la définition du
lien social je dis que c'était une
histoire de collection ou un groupe de
personnes est un sociologue français qui
s'appelle serge paugam qui a défini sur
quatre types de connexions
le premier type de connexion c'est des
liens de filiation c'est là l'élément de
lola me connaissez pas le deuxième type
de connexion c'est des biens de
participation aux élections
c'est bien que vous pouvez choisir c'est
ce que vous avez avec vos amis aucun
parent halle de sport au grade de 10
francs communautaire le troisième type
de connexion c'est du lien de
participation organique tout ce qui
touche au travail le dernier gain de
citoyenneté quasi visite donc si on
revient à la situation des jeunes
intitulé rogers et mégane fonctionne
majeur il se peut que les 4,1 soit
rendue en même temps vous allez plus
deux missions qui compte et si vous avez
déménagé
suite à la rupture familiale vous allez
plus forcément les avec vos amis si vous
habitez changer de pays puisque vous
êtes personne analyse sur l'immigration
les plus petites unités et ce qui ne
l'est pas par vos papiers vous pouvez
pas travailler au cas par cas sur 10 en
fait cette situation elle est
extrêmement complexe pour c'est jacques
est ce qu'ils sont en train en suite
parlé de leur vie ou leur second souffle
ils sont accompagnés par des
associations terrain mais ça se fait
chair sont pressés par le temps donc on
vous demande ces terrains plats une
autonomie dit alors même que vous n'avez
personne sur qui compter
il ya un problème dans ces scènes et du
vent de ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a créé
3 2 devient siècle en fait un point de
vente aura un horizon table l'idée c'est
de mettre en relation des jeunes majeurs
de 18 à 25 ans en situation de requins
familial avec des jeunes bénévoles du
nuage
le premier enjeu en veulent créer une
relation qui n'est pas naturel c'est de
se demander comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour que chaque personne du de
l'inflation prennent du temps
on a identifié trois le fait qu'ils
seront extrêmement importante premier
c'est concerne la mise en relation
comment on fait beaucoup de personnes
qui se connaissent pas arriver à
discuter beaucoup identifiés en fait des
13 personnalités on identifie aussi les
centres au matériel aussi des causes
profondes qui touchent les membres du
groupe des autres et c'est comme ça
qu'on commande perd ce match on le
deuxième levier qui est également
extrêmement dense une question sur la
posture les personnes qui par ses droits
ne démontrera notamment les montants en
leur demandant de ne pas avoir dû
posture de sauveur de héros ou héroïne
ils doivent pas aider le montrer en
pointe lui jeunes qui en situation
difficile il doit juste se contenter
établi une relation de la session du
lien social c'est vraiment important
pour que le lien social sur au centre de
la relation une troisième levier
d'action c'est le fait de trouver des
temps sans sacralisé plus que le lien
social sa part on a besoin d'avoir des
30 collective ou des pneus on se
rencontrer les personnes en sont
rencontrés et 7 ans ils seront extraits
important de ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
a revisité les classiques par exemple
des jeux société blog le times on change
un peu les indices ces risques sont
basés sur les centres d'intérêts les
dieux favorise actifs favoris de chaque
personne et qu'elle sera en fait on
apprend à se connaître mieux mais c'est
de gagner ces temps pour maxime il en
faut pour passer entre entre les
principes environnementaux
et depuis le début de ce soir devant
travailler environ une cinquantaine de
personnes qui ont participé les emballe
ci comprendra segréen à la joie pour les
ventes un camp pour les mentors et ça a
permis de développer l'empathie puisque
le fait de discuter des barèmes dans les
parcours de vie différents le fait de se
mettre à leur place à zadar merci
d'avancé sur le tout est question de
tolérance et l'ouverture d'esprit
ensuite pour les mantras salle aura
permis de répondre à la requête de
samson est ce que le fait tout
simplement deux est touché par les
marques au ces jeunes qui font face à
des obstacles de manière noble ou tiken
c'est yvan et move ont pour pensez y
penser mentor en plus de ça pour les
ventres insight est grande c'est une
grande opportunité que fait ouvrir son
réseau qu'on en a peu ça permet de se
connecter des parcours de vie qu'on a
l'habitude de voir et vous imaginez que
grandir jeune j 25 ans je pense qu'il y
en a pas mal qui français tranche d'âge
on a beaucoup de questions sur son
avenir et on peut se tourner vers moi
elles sont donc là était docteur sa mère
qui a fait une école d'ingénieurs sont
plus un cachet leur offre un parcours
artistique du pour ces jeunes qui ont
peu de connexions il n'y a pas ces
références identification positive et
105 points de vente aurait vraiment
réunies
en plus de ça après au delà de la zéro s
ancré en fait et qui apporte de la
valeur à l'échelle individuelle et
collective a créé énormément valeurs
masculines sommes en fait ils sont créés
ils participent à des projets il y en a
qui font des distributions alimentaires
pour les personnes de la rue là là deux
qui font du tonkin sportif pour
desjardins structure familiale et avait
enfin qui feront des ateliers de
sensibilisation aux enjeux écologiques
m'a dit en ouvrant un appel d'offres à
l'échelle
individuelle mais aussi collective du
coup pour finir sur une audience que
pour créer du lien social avec des
personnes en situation de grande
difficulté ce qui est vraiment important
c'est de prendre du temps mais je cite
se sentir légitime et 20 mo légitime
bascule on a tous une histoire à
partager et parce qu'on a tous à
apprendre énormément histoire de
personnes notamment celles et ceux qui
sont le plus éloignés de deux quotidiens
je pense que dans une société où on est
constamment pressé par le temps alors je
vais me déplacer
c'est important de donner du 30e salon
extrait de sa magnifique caldwell et
pour terminer la saison pour terminer
je pense qu'ici important avec les en
journée l'enjeu climatique enjeux
sociétaux c'est important de se dire que
les bruits en huitièmes ces catastrophes
place sur les personnes associations de
grandes difficultés et je n'arrive pas à
le connaître et à créer du lien à les
mobiliser et à les appliquer dans la
définition suivante d'abord
par l affaire du sens et du coup je vous
invite dans les jours qui viennent
apprendre seins nus de l'otan pour
barrer avec une percée dans en situation
de bulle et de voir l'étincelle qui
jaillit non merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]